This debate,
it will have shown you,
I hope,
that the nine/06,
vote for, your,
for your elected officials is to choose your future.
You will have understood it,
I do not want a weak Europe,
I don't want a Europe
driven by reactionaries who carry
waiting for your liberties
and your interests.
I want a strong Europe,
proud,
independent,
welcoming and free.
I want this dress of your purchasing power,
of your jobs,
our industries,
of. Um,
this Europe power that we build,
is Europe,
also,
electric vehicles at €100 per month and tomorrow
cancer vaccines.
It's, uh.
Building together,
invest together,
succeed together.
And it's not just a project.
I started,
we have
started shooting it down with my colleagues on this list.
Need Europe!
And uh.
We are with my political family,
need for Europe.
The key to all these victories
in the European Parliament,
the key to voot is the reflection
of the power of France in Strasbourg
and in Brussels.
So, uh.
The day after 09/06,
the cameras will be less
targeted at us,
but I'll be there,
always,
to continue to defend your interests.